[Music]
that's a twist
that's very twisty detective Pikachu is
our very first live-action Pokemon movie
we've wanted it since the 90s it's he
reactions a little mixed so we're gonna
talk about it are we okay with this
joining me is my friend and pokemon
master oh my gosh um I am okay with this
I love the look of this trailer I love
the direction they're going in I feel
like if you asked anyone off the street
what would be your Pokemon live-action
film this would be it I feel like beat
for a beat they be like oh there's a
poster in the back with a good missing
squirtle there's like a Charmander
walking around there's like random
Pokemon like in bars and stuff like that
I'm so damn for this I will say what I'm
not okay with okay controversial okay um
I wish they were doing ash Kanto
interest misty Brock okay
okay I want cuz that those are the
characters I've wanted to see I'm glad
we're seeing Pikachu right I'm glad
we're seeing Jigglypuff and psyduck and
all these guys but the story is is I
want misty and Brock and ash so we are
getting a Pokemon movie we're getting
Pikachu but the difference is that
Pikachu has a full-on voice of one mr.
Ryan Reynolds case closed but still open
until I solve it are we okay with this
I'm okay with this I didn't think I
would be I am okay with it I feel like
that's continuously my answer I'm okay
with it but we just saw Deadpool and
Deadpool too and he's the voice of like
everything ever yes so I do feel like
I'm watching Deadpool voiced Pikachu I I
think that now Ryan Reynolds is like if
anything comes to life or gets a voice
it's just gonna be Ryan Reynolds for now
on yes like if we have like a
live-action like Rudolph movie it's Ryan
Reynolds it's not Ryan Reynolds I'll be
like oh that's weird it's not Ryan
Reynolds it's good have been sorry that
reindeer should have been riding around
I think it's like having God in
something in it not being Morgan Freeman
exactly you're just like I'm sorry
that's wrong you know back to square one
yeah
I will electrocute you there are a lot
of other characters being brought to
life
one being mr. mime who is let's call him
terrifying yeah because he's he's got
like the peach fuzz head situation I
don't like it
are we okay with it I'm not okay that
I'm very okay with like adorable old man
mr. mime adorable adorable adorable he's
doing like his own thing he's living his
life that's what I love about mr. mime
he doesn't I don't know if mr. mime like
looks in the mirror so like I like the
fact that mr. mime is just like this is
just how I am I'm gonna live my life I
will say like I have no idea how else
mr. mine would look like as a way that
I'm actually I guess I am okay with it
now that I think about it
well on that note let us know if you
guys are okay with a live-action Pokemon
movie did mr. mime creep you out
absolutely yes we want to hear from you
I'm a - crossing on Twitter you can
always talk to me there I'm at Omer -
I'm on Twitter you can all talk to me
there and we'll see you guys next time
and we're okay with it